you
in the videos on vulgar latin and
romance nouns you learned about number
and gender the noun Lupo is masculine
Casa is feminine Lupe's
masculine plural and Casa is feminine
plural
you also found out about agreement the
article Alou matches the masculine
singular noun in Allah Lupo but the
feminine plural in Alaska says that
covers the basics of adjectives to Banu
good has forms like Bona Bona
Bonnie and Bonnie to match the noun it
describes bon I dare vana Lupo Bono and
English adjectives are said before the
noun but most romance adjectives follow
the noun he they are what Allah Allahu
Teala some adjectives have four forms
like Bono
with typical masculine and feminine
endings others just have two forms a
singular in a like Utila and a plural
like rutila's plurals work just like non
plurals so there's the expected
east-west split one any day in the east
bonus Adair's in the West he they would
Tilly in the East hideous woody less in
the West
determiners also work a lot like
adjectives these include the definite
and indefinite articles
Aleya who died ere the demonstrators for
this and that is to local east idea and
the possessives like mail my to your
nostril our may I dare not try their
question words began with quote like the
pronouns qui and quit or the adverb
quando the determiner koala for which
agrees with its now koala des koala
Sedaris
pay attention to the order of adjectives
and other agreeing words within a noun
phrase as mentioned adjectives tend to
follow the noun a few very common
adjectives like Bhanu precede the noun
on the leftmost side we find determiners
like articles or possessives
or even both articles and possessives
maiya bonito Allah meeya Bonet their
quali bone idea
classical Latin ed endings for
comparative adjectives like easier and
superlatives like easiest the modern
languages use phrases with more instead
with mice or pluse for more my spatula
blue spatula for easier than it's my
spatula quad or blue spatula quad the
superlative is most often illumise fat
ela or ela plus vehement although the
old ending ASIMO has survived for
emphasis
fatty Lisa mu meaning really easy a
small set of adjectives stubbornly
retain their old Latin comparative forms
notably bono good meliora
better but best is normally alumina an
optimum once best now means really good
or great we'll spend a few moments on
adverbs adverbs include words like
Bennett well in contact Benny sings well
and Eddy
yesterday in Eric and I languages can
also form adverbs productively out of
adjectives when Western Romance
languages attached the ending meant it
to a feminine adjective it's already
made adverb Claro clear Clara meant a
comes to mean clearly in Portuguese
French Italian and so on
Romanian didn't share in this innovation
there's so much more to share
but this quick tour has opened the door
to adjectives and adverbs in the Romance
languages
you